so we've heard so much about leveling up
over the last year or so haven't we not
just from those who propose it but also
from those who protest they don't really
know what it means and historically
there's been a lot written and a lot
said about the inequalities between
north and south but at this very moment
that we're at now post pandemic what are
the challenges and the opportunities as
well to getting this country well and
truly leveled so first of all where are
we at i want to address head on that
notion that the north routinely gets
less spent on it than the south is that
true so take a look at this firstly i
want you to pay attention only to how
high up the blobs are on this graph
first
what we've
charted along this axis here is the
total spend
per head in each region of the country
by the government in 2020 so total look
london up there at the top uh is the
most but look the northeast and the
north west actually come in second and
third however total spend doesn't really
give us the whole picture because total
spend includes things like nhs salaries
and benefits and money that sort of is
there and then it's gone so what we've
plotted along at the access at the
bottom is total investment spend
for each region of the country
investment spend going into
infrastructure and things like that and
as you can see a slightly different
story again london out there at the the
far end southeast coming second but and
although the north west not so bad the
northeast yorkshire in the humber much
further over towards here so a very
different story now crucially this is
just a moment in time this is just 2020
and of course what happens over time
incredibly important as well so what
we've charted here is the growth in
investment spend since 2016. 2016 of
course you remember just shortly after
we very first heard about the northern
powerhouse actually you can see up in
the top there the green line is the west
midlands that has had its spend grow the
most in terms of investment that's
likely a lot to do with hs2 but the
southeast coming in second there and
crucially i just want to draw your
attention to the yellow line at the
bottom yorkshire and the humber where we
currently are really one of the only
regions in the country where spend
really declined over that period peaking
just about to what it was in 2016 very
very recently there now look in terms of
regional recovery and regional
prosperity it's not just what the
government is doing that matters but
it's also what we as consumers are doing
and how we're behaving so what we've
charted here is footfall
footfall recovery in cities around the
country since the pandemic compared to
pre-pandemic levels for obvious reasons
we haven't been able to put every single
one on there could be a lot but i've
just picked out a few that i think tell
interesting stories firstly the two at
the top blackpool south end it's worth
saying there are only four cities in
four cities and towns in the whole
country where footfall is now recovered
to what it was before the pandemic or
indeed exceeding it they're all seaside
and touristy towns down at the bottom
there london sheffield that big story of
city centres just really struggling to
recover in terms of their footfall and
then in the orange barnsley we've put
that on there because there's a really
interesting story around some of these
sort of smaller regional residential
towns actually some that historically
have been a little more deprived some of
the footfall and the spenders recovered
much much better there than in other
places that's partly uh because of it's
more it's more residential people live
there and also because a lot of the
businesses in those places are more
likely to be essential so people need to
get back there for their essential spend
it matters as well what business is
doing of course a number of companies
the number of jobs the amount of
employment what we've shown you here is
the growth in the number of companies in
each region of the country since 2010 so
since that financial crisis and look
it's really clear isn't it london the
south east the south west it is still
those regions that have by far the
biggest growth in the number of
companies and we know that there's
well-documented problems with qualified
people sometimes choosing to leave uh to
travel south particularly to the capital
for work and very finally i want to
leave you with this this is incidentally
my favorite chart of the day and i think
it gives a slightly quirky look into
some of the problems we face this shows
the inequality of broadband connectivity
in different countries across the world
so the red blobs the least connected
region in each country the green blobs
the most connected region in each
country essentially what this is showing
us is that we have a greater inequality
of connectivity in this country than
colombia has certainly a greater
inequality of connectivity than denmark
has and look our worst connected region
the northeast there is by far worse off
than the vast majority of all these
other countries the u.s france spain
worth saying the same picture plays out
when you look at germany italy portugal
so i hope this gives a bit of a sense of
just how much there is to do and just
how multi-faceted the problems are if we
really want to get this country well and
truly leveled up